The bitches will love this.
That's the intro right there.
It's going to be, the bitches
will love this marks down.
Shoom shoom!
Now, recently the government
got in touch with us.
I think his email address
was like "dave@government"--
Was it?
And he said, you need to
make tennis more interesting.
And um, we came up with this.
Yeah, we did!
Basically. This is
petrol in here. Um, yeah.
And that's a tennis ball. So, soaking it
with petrol, and I'm going to serve it.
Hopefully get like a nice style, sort of
"pshh" fireball type of thing.
Now, obviously with it
being caked in petrol.
Yeah.
How are you going to stop all the petrol
from landing on your face and arm?
Uh, I've got a glove.
Yeah, that was, that's
step one, yep. Glove.
Um, a bucket of water.
I've got a helmet.
And that's uh, we're good to go I think.
All right.
Yeah.
Don't-- we don't need a canister, okay?
This is for facial
protection. I'm not, ugh.
He gets annoyed when people tell him
he's got a missing canister.
I ain't missing a canister! I know that!
It looks like an angry moment.
What am I doing here?
Whoa!
"Let me just stand here
and admire the shot
while my hand is on fire."
Well, that was a great strike.
It's, it's when I'm
filming stuff like this
that I just think, "What on
earth do we do for a living?"
Welcome to the dumbest
thing that I've ever done.
Ooh! My ass, my ass!
Well, I think that was the--
oh, you're on fire again.
Oh, cheers mate.
I think that went pretty
well. I think the government
will be very pleased with
what we accomplished.
I've got a sore ass.
Thankfully, it wasn't on fire
by the time the ball reached me.
My hand is warm.
You've got a warm hand? Well,
then it's a great video.
And um, we came up with this.
Yeah, we did. Wooh!